como lo acabas de decir era
exconsejera ex miembro del gobierno de
Carlos puignonia en 2017 decidió huir de
la justicia española tras este
referéndum Catalán junto con Carles
miembros del gobierno Catalán Ella
volvió a España justo hoy 5 años y cinco
meses después de haber huido explicó en
una rueda de prensa que venía sin
entregarse a las autoridades el Pese a
que sobre ella pesaba todavía una orden
de detención Aunque sí es verdad que
hace pocos días tras la reforma del
delito de sedición y del Código Penal en
España pues ella Desde entonces solo
está posesada por desobediencia que en
realidad es un delito menor que no
conlleva apenas de cárcel y Por ese
motivo ella se presentó aquí y pensó que
podía tener pues oportunidades de no ser
detenida no fue así ella cuando se le
acercó el policía intentó negociar decir
que tenía su acreditación de
eurodiputada y que gozaba de inmunidad
No Fue suficiente al final se la
llevaron en principio tendrían que
llevarse a un juez para tomar
declaración y podría quedar libre esta
misma noche